1997 la compagnie us robotics un petit
gadget qui va se vendre à un million
d'exemplaires ça s'appelle le pommeau
parle est un petit assistant personnel
qui a reconnu des beaux jo avant de
tomber en désuétude quand sont arrivés
les téléphones multifonctions il est
aujourd'hui enterrée ou à peu près ce
qui lui vaut une présence au cimetière
des gadgets dont le directeur général
est avec nous monsieur le directeur vous
avez eu un parent vous oui moi j'en ai
eu trois plutôt qu'un jeu j'ai eu un
palmyre 71 j'ai eu un thé xx vous ce que
vous êtes j'en ai eu 209 et vu d'aussi
bons donc il était assez répandue on ne
nous en sommes l'épreuve vivant on peut
penser que ça laisse allait faire ce que
le téléphone est déjà fait oui oui mais
ça faisait pour nous mais on n'avait pas
accès internet avec ces dispositifs là
on installait des applications je peux
si vous vous rappelez il y avait le
livre de la cia et avec toutes les
données sur tous les pays tout le monde
installé ça il y avait des conjugueur
délivre aussi en format électronique
d'autres formats dont on entend peu près
plus parler comme ça ici l'eau des
programmes pour retravailler des textes
qui étaient dans word documents to go
georges origine
c'était ce qu'on avait de mieux j'ai
parlé avec une fan du pam signe de nos
collègues journalistes à la recherche
monique lapointe elle avait encore le
sait il y a quelques mois on écoute le
moyen j'ai eu mon premier enfant en 2000
sont installés
nc186 on et ouais le truc pour recharger
on appelait prendre dans cette boîte le
je pense qu'à nos 400 jetons capable
d'ouvrir c'est très drôle à bois et pio
s'ils écoutent ce sourire
il ya aussi tout un sac de morceaux pour
réparer par exemple quand l'écran
lâchait cali p lâchait quand les touches
lâché faye avait donc pour s'éteindre et
merveilles présentes soit dans les
années 90 fin 90 et même début 2006 et
est immensément pratique c'est comme moi
dans mon métier je suis recherché ce
donc j'ai des milliers de numéros de
téléphone quand tu avais sur décarie
d'aix ça marchait poste un paquet de
trouble et puis en plus savez beaucoup
de fonctions je peux faire des
catégories c'était très utiles pour le
travail
et il fallait aussi écrire d'une façon
particulière sur le banc parce qu'il ne
reconnaissait pas l'écriture naturel oui
mais ça ça venait assez vite que tu
t'habitues et à faire des liens c'était
vraiment pour le problème est ce que
l'habitude que vous avez prises décrire
d'une certaine façon survol pendent en
quelque sorte parce que ça a été
transmis vers salle sur votre façon
d'écrire au quotidien' avec un crayon la
façon de faire lit et lieux etc ça c'est
une excellente question écoute je sais
pas c'est très possible sauf qu'on
équipe presque plus jamais à la mi mai
ce que j'adorais aussi s'était fait
qu'ils pouvaient bean et si tu veux
transmettre des informations à l'autre
personne qui devant toi là c'était
vraiment ce j'adorerais ça donc bien aux
infrarouges oui exactement
j'ai un collègue avec qui on se fait un
plaisir de son passé notre cité c'était
hyper pratique en même temps un petit
côté jeu soyons honnêtes le geek ozil
absolument c'était vraiment dans ses
choix ça valait vraiment vraiment la
peine à un moment donné que tout le
monde capoté parce que j'avais un pad
qui après ça tout le monde capoté parce
que j'étais anti diluviennes parce que
j'avais encore prendre le bus pendant
combien 12 13 ans j'ai changé parce que
j'ai transféré son amant
j'avoue que je peux plus malheureuse
maintenant est-ce que des choses qui
vous manquent de ce petit assistant
personnel que vous retrouvez pas par
exemple avec votre ipod je pense que
peut-être les catégories qui sont pas
nécessairement adaptée aux gens de
travail qu'on fait mais à part ça c'est
assez semblable comme mais le temps que
vous l'avez eu ça a été vraiment utile
par exemple si je vous comprends bien
utile immensément
immensément utile c'était très rapide en
plus non c'était vraiment je regrette
rien puis un jour les ipod depuis leur
iphone tomberait tous en panne depuis on
retournera aux pommes je serai correct
jusque là c'était plus du yen aurait pu
niveau pam oms ou risquer de tout perdre
merci beaucoup unique y'a pas de quoi
mais c'est vrai qu'on pourra encore
s'arranger avec un pareil pour les
fonctions de base le problème c'est que
maintenant qu'on a connu le petit gadget
ou un téléphone
d'internet mobile ils pas de nuage
informatique tout en le disait devait
être sur les appareils maintenance et
décentralisé et c'est tout devient
possible via les applications et
internet aux suis et je vous montre
quelque chose que vous allez tête et
mais c'est un pas envoyer 3c qui est
encore même s'il a été chargée depuis un
an voilà c'est fonctionne encore alors
faut pas l'envoyer au cimetière il est
pas mal merci beaucoup je n'écrase
centre innovant